Is it possible netflix and chill could lead
to hulu and commitment?
Hello binge watchers, Julian here for DNews.
Thanks to online streaming services like Netflix,
Hulu, and Discovery Go, it’s never been
easier to watch an episode of your favorite
show.
And then another.
And then it’s 4 am, seriously?
And while marathoning 3 seasons in one sitting
may be awful for your circadian rhythm, it
may actually be beneficial, provided you’re
not doing it alone.
A new study published in the Journal of Social
and Personal Relationships surveyed 259 college
students, asking them how much media they
shared with their partner and how close they
felt to them.
The results showed that people who shared
more media with their significant others were
more likely to report they felt closer and
more committed to them.
That’s not particularly surprising; if you
have shared interests, it’s easy to bond
over them.
But the survey also asked participants how
many friends they shared with their partner,
leading to the most interesting insight.
Results showed that the fewer friends a couple
had in common, the more impact sharing a favorite
show, movie, or book had on how close they
felt to each other.
Lead author Sarah Gomillion proposed that
this is because the characters in these shows,
movies, and books serve as substitutes for
a common friends circle, compensating for
their lack of a social reality with a social
fiction.
Interestingly, the desire to share other activities,
like a dinner date, was unaffected by how
many friends the couple had in common, further
suggesting that the characters in the movies,
shows or books were indeed serving as a replacement
for a common friends group.
This makes sense when you look at past research
that has found couples with common friends
feel more connected and committed, and that
people tend to form emotional bonds with fictional
characters.
So a couple may feel the need to compensate
when they have no friends in common, say because
they met through a dating app and one invited
the other over for netflix and chill, and
before they knew it they were 5 seasons deep
in Parks and Rec and chiller than Elsa.
So binge watching can make you feel like you
have friends, but that’s not always a good
thing.
A 2015 study by doctoral students at the University
of Texas at Austin found that people who were
lonely and depressed were more likely to binge
watch television, which can cause them to
neglect their health or other relationships.
And if someone is neglecting their health
and relationships, it stands to reason they’ll
become even more depressed and lonely, and
eventually they’ll run out of episodes and
their TV friends will be gone.
Bonding with an actual human who sticks around
after the series finale could be crucial to
avoiding this.
But what if your special someone is gone,
and you miss your TV pals?
Is it alright to sneak in a few episodes without
them?
What Gomillion’s study effectively means
is when you get a few episodes of Thrones
ahead, you’re not just getting to the juicy
bits first, you’re effectively hanging out
with all your partner’s friends without
them!
Luckily someone has thought of a solution,
and that someone is -- of all someones -- the
Italian ice cream maker Cornetto.
They’ve made what they call Commitment Rings,
which sync to an app that will let you watch
shows and movies only when both rings are
present.
So if you and your partner are working your
way through Shaun of the Dead, Hot Fuzz, and
The World’s End together, you can thank
Cornetto for bringing you closer together.
Some couples may need to avoid their friends
because their relationship’s a secret.
Seeker Stories has a story about dating in
India And if you want to know about something
more scandalous that Netflix and chilling,
check out guest host Ali’s ins and outs
of sending dirty pictures.
How do you get closer to your significant
other?